[Music]
the truth about america has been
obscured and deleted by the far american
left but in this week's
sunday special we will be bringing it to
you our show is sponsored by
expressivevpn your online activity
shouldn't be public protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
ben as you all know i have a new book
out it's called how to destroy america
in three easy steps
and this week's podcast we're gonna go
down memory lane with some folks
we talk about what about america is
worth preserving because that really is
the battle
right now it's not between right and
left so much as it is between people
who wish for the country to continue and
people who wish for the country to be
destroyed well if you wish for the
country to continue
you have to find some points of
commonality now in my viewpoint that
means
a common philosophy culture and history
a belief that the
founding principles of the declaration
of independence were indeed self-evident
and correct that you have natural rights
that pre-exist government
that limited government was designed in
order to protect those rights
and that if the government were to
invade those rights it would lose its
reason for being
we have to share a culture a culture
where we tolerate each other's exercise
of rights even if we don't necessarily
like
how those rights are being exercised we
have to cultivate a culture of adventure
and entrepreneurship where the only
thing guaranteed is adventure
and you are basically expected to pick
up the slack you're expected
to make the right decisions we have to
cultivate a culture where social
institutions
are valued and where we value our
neighbors without that culture all of
this falls in on itself
and finally we have to share a common
history a belief that the history of the
united states is the perfection of a
principle
it is not in fact a headlong rush away
from founding principle we have to
believe that american history
is the story of living up to the
principles set out in the declaration of
independence
not the story of various groups clubbing
each other over the head
for purposes of power relations if we
believe that the country is going to
fall apart
but one thing is obvious there is a vast
group in the united states that is
seeking to dissolve all the bonds that
tie us together
there are normal conversations that
happen between people on the right and
the left
about just how far founding principles
extend about just how much further we
have to go
but then there are folks who just want
to bathe the entire thing in acid and
this is what you see from the robin
d'angelo crowd this is what you see from
ibram candy
the basic idea being that the american
system itself is deeply disgusting
the american system itself is rooted in
brutality and evil and racism and
bigotry
and the only way to fight against that
is to tear down the system
itself well if we don't know what we're
standing for it's going to be very
difficult to stand against the winds
that are about to blow
increasingly in the united states we
don't know what we stand for
increasingly in the united states our
cultural institutions have fallen down
on the job or been taken over by the
disintegrationists who wish to see all
of these common ties
fall apart i think in this week's
episode you'll see the reasons why we
have to hold together you're gonna see a
lot of people disagree about a variety
of topics
but they are all operating inside the
rubric that suggests
that the american flag stands for
freedom that the declaration of
independence was in its essence correct
and that the future of america lies in
recognizing what we share
rather than what divides us we're
bringing you the best moments from the
last two years of shows with unique
perspectives surrounding a topic and
some of my own reflections on the
collection
this week we focus on several guests
discussing the things that unify and the
things that break down america
highlighting the aspects of america we
must hold on to in order to take back
the country
and fend it off from utter destruction
the topics in this video are also
covered extensively in my brand new
best-selling book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps it's crushing sales records it's
coming in at the top of every bestseller
chart if you want an antidote to
divisive stupidity like white fragility
and how to be an anti-racist
head on over to amazon or
barnesandnoble.com and pick up your copy
today
now before we continue we're going to
look at a couple of awesome responses we
received from past guests
first from william lane craig who's
featured in our judeo-christian values
collection
asked about the chaos we're seeing
around america the past few months dr
craig says quote
as we go through these tumultuous times
it's important for each of us
personally to keep in mind the ethics of
jesus including respect for all persons
love of one's enemies turning the other
cheek at personal insult
submission to governmental authorities
and above all love for god
dr craig thanks so much for sending the
letter it's always great to hear from
you
we also released a collection of
favorite moments from the intellectual
dark web
in response to her segment christina
hoff summers sent this letter
to us quote hey ben enjoyed your
retrospective on the intellectual dark
web
i was just thinking back to november
2016 when i replaced you as a yaf
speaker at depaul university
he'd been banished from that campus by
some frightened clueless pusillanimous
administrators
we hatched a plan to subvert the ban you
were going to sit in the audience and i
would invite you on stage
unfortunately campus security nabbed you
and forbade you set foot
on campus so am i to understand that if
i take three steps forward do all the
time to have me arrested
if you create a problem and you will not
you know leave the campus yes
okay so undeterred you called my cell
phone from off campus and invited me and
the 200 plus audience
to join you in a nearby bar it had sort
of a theater dungeon in the basement
if you want to hear me speak and you
wanna hear christina finish her lecture
just head over to the green room theater
about point seven miles away
you can follow us there it'll be great
okay did you hear that
we're going to be happily marched off
the little island of oppression known as
depaul you
into the sea of freedom called america
but now i'm worried about that sea of
freedom
the sad fact is we may look back at our
depaul events as the good old days
at least we have the dungeon there seems
to be a new level of woke fanaticism and
safe space
neo-marxism permeating the culture as
andrew sullivan says we all live on
campus now
suddenly identity politics and its
dreary mind-numbing thought annihilating
lexicon
white supremacy toxic masculinity
interlocking oppressions
is everywhere large swaths of elite
journalism hollywood silicon valley even
corporate america
are not simply going the way of the
campus they are going full evergreen
state
so am i pessimistic well not entirely at
least no sane person can any longer deny
the existence of cancer culture
as air force vet rob henderson said on
twitter when people say there's no such
thing as cancer culture
it reminds me of season one episode five
when tony soprano tells his daughter
there is no mafia
and as more people realize what is going
on resistance to it will grow
it's already happening no movement so
bereft of humor forgiveness
rationality basic sanity can survive in
the land of the free for too long
at least i hope not so keep doing what
you're doing i'll see you on stage at
depaul when this is all over all the
best christina
christina thanks so much for sending the
letter it's always great to hear from
you i hope you're doing well
we're going to jump in with our first
guest tucker carlson in just a minute
but before that
we are so grateful for our advertising
partners i want to remind you that this
show can be brought to you
mainly because our advertisers advertise
it with us so please keep patronizing
our sponsors they appreciate it we
appreciate it too and this is why we
ought to talk
about policy genius policy genius is one
of our great sponsors
these days a lot of people thinking can
i actually shop for life insurance you
can indeed shop
for life insurance shopping for life
insurance these days raises a lot of
questions how much coverage do you need
which insurance company is the best one
for you how much should it even cost
at a time when it's important to have
life insurance the pandemic is making it
a little more complicated to shop for it
but don't worry
this is where policy genius can help as
a life insurance marketplace backed by a
team of experts
policy genius is keeping track of all
the changes in the market so you don't
have to
they'll find you the right amount of
coverage at the best possible price
without the headache
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies all in one
place
it takes just a few minutes to compare
quotes from those top insurers you can
find your best price
it doesn't take a lot of legwork you
could say 1500 bucks or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free so
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they will be there
to take care of everything really you
should protect the people who rely on
you that is the responsible thing to do
go check out policy genius right now
head on over to policygenius.com it'll
help you find the best rate they'll
handle the process completely
soup to nuts they'll get you and your
family protected policygenius.com
on the topic of free speech and the
threat to it in the country right now we
start with tucker carlson
this past week tucker talked on his show
about the new york times releasing a
story revealing the location of his
family's home
tucker like many of us has been long
harassed and threatened by people who
disagree with him
tucker is without a doubt one of the
leading political voices in the country
he's been the host of the fox news show
tucker carlson tonight for the past four
years this year he became
the highest rated primetime cable news
show in the country before fox news
tucker was a host for programs at cnn
and msnbc
totaling over 10 years of hosting cable
news tv a tucker is one of the most
fascinating
minds in american public life there's so
much that we agree on and so much that
we disagree on
i think we disagree very largely on the
role of government and american life
government choosing winners and losers
is it the job of government
to push certain social institutions at
the expense of other social institutions
how should government be used in order
to prop up certain institutions
as opposed to general rules of liberty
and then social and cultural
institutions
filling the gap the way the way that i
propose but one thing we certainly agree
on
is the neo-marxist left and their
absolute willingness to destroy every
hallmark of the country tucker is
extraordinarily strong on that stuff
he and i are in total agreement on all
of that for sure in episode 26
tucker notes the inversion of truth in
the phrase diversity is our strength
and how our ruling class has divided the
country
[Music]
issue number one is sort of the free
speech issue people should be able to
say what they want people should be able
to
you lead their families how they want to
lead them they were in complete
agreement
right and i think that you know the the
unity of the right is largely based on
agreement on this particular point
the foundational questions without which
none of the rest is possible
right and free expression would be one
um
of course in freedom of conscience right
and you talk a lot in ship of fools
particularly
about the threat to these sorts of ideas
from a left that is focused on a sort of
forced diversity and you've been
labeled racist by folks in media matters
for this of course because they label
everyone a racist i'm a nazi according
to media matters because of myamica
apparently but
your your viewpoint on diversity is
basically as i see it expressed in the
book
that diversity is a neutral it doesn't
it's not good
or bad inherently it's not a value
description right and so where do you
see the conflict lying between
right and left on that particular so
where i agree with you is that
you know while as i noted i am
distrustful of
complex ideologies i do think that you
need to
start with certain things that you
believe are true and act
on them if you want to get to the place
you desire to be so
um what i just noticed just as an
american and i'm not an intellectual i'm
a talk show host so this is a very
obvious thing
that our national motto has been
redefined to
its mirror image so of course it was out
of many one
and now it is diversity is our strength
so i think it's fair if you without
asking my consent replace the core
principle of our country it's fair for
me to ask if that principle
is worth organizing a country around so
i'll just ask the obvious question
is diversity our strength and of course
like so much they say
it's not only untrue it's the opposite
of what is true
it is never true that diversity is
respect i'm for all kinds of diversity
but they're not our strengths in other
words is it true in your marriage the
less you have in common with your
wife the stronger your marriage is we
don't speak the same language that's why
we love each other
is it true in your business we don't
know what we're all doing it's true in
the military no it's insane actually
it's the opposite once again of what is
true what is
observably true so i just noted that and
by the way at the same time i noted it
as i did you know 50 nights in the past
200 nights
i made the case explicitly against
racism
which is you are not responsible for
your immutable qualities you can't
control your height your hair color your
dna
what your parents did none of that is
your fault and you should not be
punished for it or rewarded for it that
is an argument against racism
explicitly and so for that i'm a racist
it's like no you don't understand
i'm arguing against all kinds of racism
i think it's
a really dangerous way to see the world
and anyway whatever they don't mean
anything they say
they throw at you the very things that
they are doing in order to silence you
and i just happen for this brief window
of my life to have the freedom to say
what i think is true and i'm going to
there's a lot of talk these days about
political realignment and i wonder if
it's not really political realignment
that's taking place but
a hunkering down of the far left into
the diversity politics identity politics
and then just the backlash to that
because it seems to me that was the real
dividing line
between obama and trump is not even on
economics where
in some areas there's actually some sort
of populist agreement but it's really on
these sort of cultural divisions where
president obama was
was basically saying you know we can be
divided into
various ethnic groups all of whom have
been victimized by america and then we
can create a coalition of the
dispossessed
to come back in and sweep into power and
the new demographic
shift will will basically buoy our boat
all the way to victory
from now until the end of time and then
the backlash for that was well wait a
second
you know you guys don't get to do
identity politics when you've been
saying that identity politics is what's
wrong with america for generations
correctly
so why are you doing that now well as a
practical matter it just doesn't work
i mean countries don't hang together by
accident particularly
large diverse ones that don't have a
majority in any category so there's no
if you don't even have a shared language
or history or culture
you know why would you coal you know why
would you remain
united as a country and the answer which
i actually believe in
is that you could hang together around a
common idea
a common set of beliefs here's what
we're all for but our ruling class and i
do think this is the least responsible
the most reckless thing they have done
is they have not only failed to come up
with what that set of common beliefs is
they have argued against
the fact that it should exist
and so like that and what they're doing
clearly is i mean it's not
complicated they're dividing in order to
rule of course what the british did in
india
but that's the shortest term thinking i
mean that's like day trader thinking
do you know what i mean yeah yeah so
what do you think is are those common
ideals you say that you know there's
certain things that you think are just
basic to being american
what are those common ideas i mean i
guess i'd start with the bill of rights
i mean that's not hard
do you know what i mean since it is a
founding document it's the foundational
document
and i think look you'll notice the book
is long on diagnostics
and short on solutions because
that reflects who i am and what i do i'm
not a policy maker
at all i'm an observer i'm not a deep
systematic thinker
again i'm a talk show host right so i'm
pretty good at telling you what i think
is wrong
it's not as clear how you fix it other
than
go back to the obvious things like
demand that everybody who comes to this
country for economic opportunity for
example
um or for the safety of our rule of law
also buy into the things that makes
all of us americans like it's not it's
not complicated really
um so yeah i would start with the bill
of rights like you have
an absolute right as defined in 1967 by
the supreme court
but also by sort of centuries of
tradition here in this country which we
inherited from another
culture across the ocean to believe what
you believe
unmolested period it's an absolute right
you can't violate my conscience
and that right is under assault not by a
political party but by in effect a
secular evangelical faith
which we're calling progressive or
liberal or whatever but it's not it's a
species of religion
that seeks to convert by force and that
is deeply
anguished and concerned that other
people disagree so like i doubt you go
home tonight and fret at any length over
the idea that somewhere in williamsburg
brooklyn someone disagrees with you on
it she's just probably not
thinking about wait exactly i'm not
famous for my camera but i can promise
you somewhere in williamsburg right now
someone is
lying in a studio apartment fretting
that in the you know
the far reaches of red clay alabama
someone's not fully on board with the
bathroom program like they're really
bothered by that
and they need to do something about it
so actually it's an asymmetrical contest
between
one group that wants to affect policy
outcomes and the other group that wants
to convert by the sword
so it's the religious people versus the
political people and i don't even think
we acknowledge that most of the time
larry is the host of the radio talk show
the larry elder show which has been on
the air in los angeles since 1994.
he's the author of the best-selling book
the 10 things you can't say in america
amongst others
just last month a documentary larry
produced uncle tom
was released the film explores what it's
like to be a minority within a minority
a black conservative
you can find that film right now at
uncle tom.com i love larry larry is just
fantastic actually the first radio show
i ever did was the larry elder show i
was 16 years old i was at ucla
and larry hosted me on the show to talk
about radicalism at the
ucla daily bruin so larry and i have a
long glorious history
i'm a big larry elder fan one of the
most formative people in in my thinking
when it came to libertarianism for sure
in episode 39
larry discusses all the ways that
president obama a full-on
disintegrationist contributed in
dividing america
and stressed our race relations looking
back on this conversation larry sent us
some thoughts
we're in a new place when someone as
respected and as respectable as new
orleans saints quarterback drew brees
feels a need to apologize for saying he
would quote never agree with anyone who
disrespects the flag
the next day he apologizes again and
again the following day and then his
wife apologizes
whoever said compound interest was the
greatest force in the universe never
encountered white guilt
where are we with this cancel culture
some activists are petitioning to remove
john wayne's name from the john wayne
airport because of remarks considered
racially intemperate wayne made
in a 1971 playboy interview in 1958
martin luther king wrote an advice
column for ebony magazine a gay black
teen in the closet wrote him seeking
advice
on what the young man considered his
sexual confusion king gave advice that
today would be considered homophobic if
not abusive
king told him to pray and consult a
psychiatrist harry truman without whose
support as president the modern state of
israel might not have come into
existence
in a 1911 letter to his future wife
referred to jews as the k-word
and new york as k-town and used a number
of other ethnic slurs
do we cancel him trump was criticized
for referring to haiti and some african
countries
as bleephole countries president john f
kennedy according to a former new york
times investigative reporter
once derisively referred to some african
countries as quote boogie republics
do we remove his name from jfk airport
here larry and i discuss the recent
surge in division and
intersectionality and refute the idea
that america is a racist country
[Music]
so larry i want to ask you about a
philosophy that seems to have taken over
the democratic party
almost wholesale and that is the
philosophy of intersectionality
as a precursor to that i want to get
your opinion on the legacy of barack
obama because it's my opinion that
intersectionality really
became a thing under the obama
presidency people try to blame president
trump for the rise in increased racial
tensions in the united states but if you
look at the polls what the polls say is
that americans were pretty optimistic
across the racial spectrum before barack
obama became president barack
obama became president and then things
started to sink pretty quickly and i
think a lot of that has to do with the
fact that
americans elected president obama under
the auspices of he was going to be a
great uniter somebody who tried to get
us beyond race
he in his own persona was unification of
black and white considering his father
was black and his mother was white right
this is what he ran on
and then instead of coming forth and
saying listen we can all call out racism
together when we see it but not every
problem is a race problem
a lot of problems are just people
problems and maybe we should do that
instead of him doing that he decided to
build an intersectional coalition around
himself
and then suggest that people who
disagreed with him were inevitably
racist i want to get your opinion on on
barack obama's impact on sort of the
race debate in the united states you
know i was in
the boston arena in 2004 when obama gave
that speech for john kerry
and he brought the house down i was with
my producer
and people were cheering there's no blue
america there is no red america it's
just united states of america yeah
there's no black americans yeah and i
said to him
this guy's gonna run for president he's
gonna get elected he didn't say a damn
thing but he said it well
and so obama gets elected and you're
absolutely right i believe that uh
people voted for him in large part
because they thought that he was going
to put the nail in the coffin that
america is a racist society finally we
can now move on
a number of people i think pull the
lever for him because of that
and he proceeds to do
just the opposite before he became
president
he gave a speech as a senator at a
church in atlanta and he was talking
about how much racism there is in
america
and he said the generation of mlk the
moses generation
has quote gotten us 90 of the way there
close quote to realizing mlk's dream of
a
society where people evaluate you based
on content of character and i thought
that was reasonable ninety percent
uh ten percent of americans believe
elvis is still alive eight percent
believe if you say miller he'll get it
uh seven percent of adults believe that
uh
chocolate milk comes from brown cows 25
of adults say they're not sure so
you can't get much below 10
uh and then he said the generation my
generation
the joshua generation he said has to
give us that additional 10
that was before he got elected let alone
re-elected let alone back-to-back
attorneys general who are black
so i would think that 10 percent has
been worked into just a little bit
when he ran in 2008 you wouldn't find
him and al sharpton on the same plane
together
second time he ran al sharpton come to
the white house something like
over 70 times over the course of his uh
of his presidency
the first opportunity that that obama
had to reconcile
to do what people thought he was going
to do was the cambridge police incident
you remember that the professor from
harvard had forgotten his
uh door key he was on vacation came home
uh
realized he didn't have his door key and
he and the cab driver pushed the door
and broke into his own home
a neighbor sees this calls 9-1-1 don't
you want neighbors to do that
cop shows up very politely asked the
skip gates to come out of this house and
he
cops a tude and says something like uh
i'll come out if your mama tells me to
come out
and instead of obama going on television
saying look skip i know you're a friend
of mine you and i have been friends a
long time
but you have done exactly the wrong
thing for for
young black boys instead of being
respectful
instead of responding to the request you
copped an attitude
this is exactly why a lot of young black
people are getting killed by the police
because
they look at this as a confrontation
instead of following instructions my
father told me whenever i'm pulled over
by the police make sure your hands at
ten o'clock
your right hand's at two o'clock you say
yes sir say no sir make sure your
paperwork is in order
and if you feel you're mistreated get a
badge number write it down and you and i
will deal with it while we're both still
alive
that's what obama could have said and
should have said and did it instead he
said the cambridge police acted stupidly
and the cops didn't realize that he was
not on their side
and obama fumbled around with that
stupid beer thing to try and uh
walk it back a little bit but they also
he had he had several chances
trayvon martin if i had a son he would
look like trayvon i don't know what that
even means
um and of course trayvon martin was
found not guilty and
uh the jurors said race never even came
up
there were no blacks on the jury but
there was a black alternate and the
alternate said
he would have voted the same way not not
guilty and race was not a factor
obama gave a speech um before the united
nations and invoked ferguson
now this is why ferguson was still being
investigated
uh this cop was assumed to have been a
racist a michael brown
allegedly had his hands up don't shoot
and obama mentions this to a united
nations
address and says we have our own
problems a place called ferguson
ferguson turned out to be a complete
force as you know
and the doj comes in exonerates the the
uh
the cop but nevertheless says that the
ferguson pd is institutionally racist
and their biggest takeaway was this 67
percent of the population of ferguson is
black
18 of those who are stopped for traffic
stops are black
18 point gap ergo racism the
ferguson pd they had two or three blacks
outside of that there were 50 whites
if that's true why isn't the nypd even
more institutionally racist
25 of black people live in the uh 25 the
population of
new york is black 55 of the traffic
stops lower of black people that's a 30
point gap
yet the majority of new york cops are
either women or people of color
so how come that isn't is more racist
and the answer is you can't do it by
numbers you have to do it by
differences in offending and there's a
report that came out in 2013 under the
obama administration
by the national institutes of justice
which is a research arm of the doj
called race and traffic stops and they
looked at this 75 of the black motors
admitted that they were stopped for
legitimate reasons
uh and the commission found that
differences in offending and differences
in driving counted for the difference
couldn't find any evidence of racism uh
years ago
uh in new jersey black motorists were
being stopped disproportionately by the
new jersey turned
new jersey troopers and they were
yelling and screaming about racism
christy todd whitman ordered a study a
study came back and said
the faster the car the more likely it is
to be a black guy
couldn't find any evidence of of of
racism didn't like the study didn't like
the conclusion threw it out
hired a different person different
methodology same conclusion
sorry just not there these things have
been measured and studied over and over
again
every every two or three years doj
conducts something called the police
public
uh contact survey have you been stopped
by the police how are you treated
are you black are you white uh did
anything happen nothing
no no pattern it's just a lie and so
people like
like eric holder the naacp barack obama
have been perpetuating this bs lie and
in my opinion they do it because they
want that 95 percent
monolithic black vote without which they
cannot succeed and if black started
thinking of themselves as individuals
and not as
as an aggrieved group and start looking
at things like
the crappy public school that i'm
mandated to go to
job killing laws like minimum wage
they would rethink their assumptions
with the democratic party and their
democratic party is definitely afraid of
that and that's why they have to malign
people like larry elders uncle toms
uh and and slam other people as as
racist because you cannot get
95 of people to think a certain way
unless you lie to them
well speaking of speaking of that one
one of the ways that this this has been
intellectualized is in this philosophy
of intersectionality and the philosophy
has been put out there basically that
historically a lot of groups in the
united states specifically black people
most of all obviously
have been victimized by the power
hierarchy of the hierarchy was set up
for that end then the only way to fight
back against that power hierarchy and
institutions of power
is to band together in groups that think
they can get then get together
themselves
and then attack that hierarchy and tear
it down from the inside out the only way
if you are
on the top of the power hierarchy if
you're if you're a white male for
example the only way that you
get out of this unfortunate situation is
by acknowledging and reading ta-nehisi
codes apparently
see the pro the problem with all of this
is that in order to escape poverty and
get to the middle class
this has been studied by the left and by
the right and they agree
if you look at the brookings institution
and the heritage foundation they're
diametrically opposed on many issues but
on the formula to get from the poverty
to the middle class
they all say the same thing finish high
school first
number two don't have a kid before
you're 20. number three get married
before you have the kid and they phrase
it a little bit differently but that's
what all three of them have said
and if you argue as obama did that a kid
raised without a father is five times
more likely to be poor
nine times more likely to drop out of
school and 20 times more likely to end
up in jail that is the number one
problem facing america
and if slavery and jim crow had this
effect how do we go from having 25 black
uh
out of wedlock birth in 1965 to almost
70 percent now
i would think that anybody would argue
were less racist today than we were in
so you can't attribute it to that in
fact during slavery
a black child was more likely to be to
be born under a roof with his biological
mother and biological father
than today it is the number one problem
facing this country not racism
take a magic wand and wave it over
america and remove every smidgen of
racism from the hearts of white america
50 inner city dropout rate in some
schools 70 of black kids born outside of
wedlock as i mentioned 25
of young black boys have criminal
records the cdc just said that a
young black man is 10 times more likely
to be the victim of a homicide
compared to a white person and the
number one cause of preventable death
for young white men
are accidents like car accidents the
number one cause of preventable
cause of death for young black men is
homicide almost always at the hands of
another black
person chicago a third black a third
white a third hispanic 70 of the
homicides are black on black
and about 75 percent of those men are
unsolved and we're talking about
intersectionality get out of here
get out of here now let's look at
someone i admire who speaks to the
experience of growing up being taught
the value and blessings of liberty in
america
and later found herself in the debate
over the historical symbols in the
american south
nikki haley is perhaps best known as the
us ambassador to the united nations from
2017 to 2018
under the trump administration she was
governor of the state of south carolina
from 2011 to 2017 and she's the author
of the new york times bestselling book
with all due respect defending america
with grit
and grace so as you all know nikki haley
is my spirit animal i love nikki haley
she's just the sweetest person
on earth i also happen to know her
family wonderful wonderful human being
and a true conservative in every sense
of the word she really thinks through
the policies that she promotes and she
is strong and stands up against people
who refuse to give her the respect to
which she is due which is something that
i think
feminists should take note of when they
rip her down in a couple years when she
runs for president
in june 2015 while nikki was governor a
tragic shooting occurred at mother
emanuel in african american church in
charleston south carolina
a hateful shooter proudly displayed a
confederate flag on his manifesto
and as a result nikki made the decision
to remove the flag from the state
capital
in this discussion from episode 49 nikki
details that decision
and explains why removing a confederate
flag is different than removing a
confederate monument
but first listen to us discuss the
virtue of hard work and patriotism
she learned being raised by an immigrant
family
[Music]
well you know first i was born in a
small rural town in south carolina
we were the only indian family we
weren't white enough to be white we
weren't black enough to be black
my father wears the turban my mom at the
time were sorry
no one knew who we were what we were or
why we were there
and so growing up like that i was always
different
i was always an other and i remember
coming home after being bullied
and my mom would always say your job is
not to show how you're different
your job is to show how you're similar
and it's interesting because
going through life i've treated
everything like that so the same thing
that happened
as a five-year-old on the playground is
the same thing i did
when i was a governor it's what i did as
an ambassador is
when you have challenges it's a lot
easier if you will
go through all the things you agree on
first and then go to the challenge
because it puts everybody's guard down
it all of a sudden lets them relate to
you a little bit more and so those kinds
of things
really impacted everything i did i
started doing the books for my
parents business when i was 13. i did
not know that wasn't normal
until i got to college now i know it's
child labor
and i tell them that all the time but it
was there that i learned the value of a
dollar
you know when times were tough in our
small business
i knew that we had to hunker down we got
creative we got lean
and we got smart and then when times
were good we never celebrated because we
knew it wouldn't last forever
and i carried that whole mindset to my
love of numbers
and that's when i went to clemson go
tigers
and graduated with a degree in
accounting went to corporate america
and worked there for a bit and then i
came back home to the family business
and it was there that again my mom heard
me
saying how hard it was to make a dollar
and how easy it was for government to
take it and my mom said quit complaining
about it do something about it
how did your family react when you said
that you're running for office your
husband your kids
how did they react to that it's
difficult my kids were little um
i think they were three and six at the
time so they didn't really know they
would cheer on every time they'd see
like a four by eight billboard they'd be
like mom and they'd cheer me on they
were my only cheering committee because
no one knew who i was so
michael has always been unbelievably
supportive
he's never said no he's never said don't
do it he's always said
yeah you can do this you should go ahead
so
and of course my parents you know being
immigrants
when you have immigrants immigrant
parents
they're so patriotic they're so grateful
and my parents literally there was not a
day that went by where my brothers
my sister and me didn't hear from my
parents about how blessed we were to be
in this country
and how we had to remember that and so
that feeling they always encouraged us
to do anything
my husband was always supportive at
everything and then the kids i think
just went along for the ride
so as governor of south carolina i think
the first time that a lot of people saw
you on the national stage
was the controversy with regards to the
removal of the confederate battle flag
from the from the war monument that was
outside the state capitol building i
believe
uh so maybe you can take us through your
thinking on that it
emerged the whole controversy emerged in
the aftermath of the horrible terrorist
attack on the on the
historically black church in south
carolina they didn't take us through
logic on that because i know that that
raised
a lot of ire on both sides and uh and
obviously you had to take a tough
position
i mean it was painful it was absolutely
painful here was
on a wednesday night 12 people did what
a lot of people in south carolina did
they went to bible study mother emanuel
is one of the oldest
african-american churches it's a
beautiful church
and people typically families for
generations go
to that church and but on that night
someone else showed up and he didn't
look like them
he didn't sound like them he didn't act
like them
but they didn't kick him out they didn't
call the police
they pulled up a chair and they prayed
with him for an
hour and in that last
prayer when they bowed their heads he
started to shoot
these were people who lived their life
every day
just trying to be good they took care of
their families
they had jobs they went to church it was
what every south carolinian
did and the pain of that
and the fact that it was in the most
sacred of places
that was the part i couldn't get my
heart around
was when you go to a place of worship
that's you're with god that's like that
that's your closest
closest feeling to god and you feel the
safest
and you feel like you can let your guard
down and you're you're most vulnerable
and the idea that someone could do this
in a church
was just pure hate and i remember going
to
my law enforcement director and i said
chief
please tell me he had a mental illness
i so wanted him to say that and he said
he didn't
so once we knew it was hate i knew that
i had to
protect the state but my bigger problem
was i had to keep the national media out
they so wanted in on this they wanted to
define it
they wanted to talk about it in their
terms they wanted to talk about the
solutions
and i literally had to just push them
off and say
stop we're going to have these funerals
we're going to give the respect to these
families
and during that time it was a
presidential primary
so all the candidates wanted to weigh in
on it so i was on the phone with the
candidates telling them to stay out
but the beautiful part was that next day
when the killer presented himself for
the first time in front of the judge
those families unscripted unrehearsed
not having talked to each other
walked up looked the killer in the eye
and forgave him
i mean that kind of forgiveness through
their
pain they forgave him and prayed for him
and there's so many lessons that can be
learned through that
and the people of south carolina they
didn't protest they had vigils
they didn't have riots they had hugs
and so from that standpoint it was a
healing time
the problem was that the killer
did a manifesto and the very
picture on the manifesto was him
standing there with the confederate flag
so now the confederate flag in south
carolina
by many was viewed as heritage
service family
history there was a real traditional
component to it
and then the others who know it as you
know what people remember in slavery and
all of those things so you had this one
group of people
that saw it as a part of them saw it as
a part of their tradition
but literally after i saw that image and
that image went all over the world
i knew that something had to be done and
so
that next day we announced that we were
going to bring the flag down
it was a tough debate um what made it
hard is we had to have two-thirds vote
in both the house and the senate
um and you know it was just a matter of
i think there was a little bit of
you know just communication a lot of
prayer
and just believing in the people in
south carolina and so
yes it was a tough debate what i made
sure
i communicated was a flag is a living
breathing
representative symbol
a monument is very different
a monument represents a moment in
history
a past moment in time so i made it very
clear to my state
that look the flag needs to come down
because i don't want a single child to
look at that flag and feel pain
or see the killer's face or any of that
but we're not going to start taking down
monuments
because those are monuments we learn
from that's how we make sure we never
forget
so what we did on the monument side was
an african-american museum
went up a monument to the mother emanuel
and tribute went up
that's how that needs to be handled if
you take down a monument you're not
erasing history
you're just taking something down
thinking you proved a point when you
didn't
you just erased a lesson
to better understand american history we
have david barton a historian and the
founder of wall builders an organization
that presents america's forgotten
history and heroes
with an emphasis on our moral religious
and constitutional heritage
he's authored many best-selling books he
serves as a consultant to state and
federal legislators and even helped to
develop the history and social studies
standards
for states like texas and california
newsmax named him one of america's top
most influential evangelicals time
magazine put him in the top 25.
so meeting david barton was super cool
especially because he brought a ton
of historical items i am a historic
memorabilia nut
i mean his collection is just
astonishing and wonderful literally the
only person i know
whose collection is anywhere near this
is glenn beck but david barton's i think
even trump says
i also have his founder's bible sitting
on my desk at home
so we actually just heard from david
barney sent us a letter here's what he
had to say
ben and i had an extensive discussion
about the substantial positive impact
religious thought belief and practice
had on america's founding fathers
the overwhelming majority of the more
than 200 of them with only a few
exceptions were men of deeply devout and
pious biblical faith
they took deliberate steps to ensure
that america would never become
secularist in education
government or the public square but
today most americans know so little of
our history that they believe just the
opposite which has led to bad public
policy
we are seeing this same pattern repeated
with the current attacks on our
foundational cultural and historical
ideas and symbols
many of the statues being torn down were
actually early pioneers leading the
fight against racism
and had historic breakthroughs in
changing the policies of their day
none of them were perfect but even
thomas jefferson was the first to
announce to the world that america
wanted to end the slave trade and he was
the first leader of any nation to sign a
law banning the international slave
trade
as a result of the efforts of so many
founding fathers america became the
fourth nation in the world to ban
slavery making us one of the earliest
anywhere on the globe
yet we want to tear down the statues of
those who helped move the world in the
right direction
the portrayal of american history today
is too often reduced to historically
inaccurate memes and ridiculously
simplistic sound bites
our historical knowledge affects our
public policy if our laws are built on
an inaccurate view of the past
then they will be ineffective at best
and onerous at worst but if they are
built on a foundation of truth they can
be effective
in achieving good david thanks so much
for sending that in obviously
our conversation was great and go listen
to that in the back catalog or part of
it today
from episode 57 david and i discuss the
founding fathers and their reliance and
encouragement of religious thought
george washington's warnings and wise
words from his farewell address
and the real meaning of the separation
of church and state
of the things that you've been talking
about a lot and is really important to
me i mean i wrote a book that largely
concerns this
is the impact of religious thought on
american founding thought so
obviously you've mentioned it a couple
of times you should hone in on it
there's this idea that's taught in
schools that effectively america
is a secular country that it was founded
along the idea of separation of church
and state
to this end the first amendment is is
often cited the idea that you can't
establish a religion
and then forgetting about the second
half which is that there's freedom of
religion
the so what exactly in your view was the
relationship of founding thought
to religion how much did the founders
rely on religious thought and
what did they think in terms of
governance and religion how those two
should be balanced
they were very adamant that you do not
separate religious principles now
doctrines are one thing
religious principles are something else
and so when they said there should be no
establishment religion
back then an establishment of religion
was a state established religion
they had no trouble with religion they
promoted it the first
federal law that was passed dealing with
how you become a territory in the united
states is called the northwest ordinance
george washington signed that on on
august the 7th of 1789
that's how 32 states became states in
the united states
and that law specifically says article 3
religion morality and knowledge being
necessary to good government and the
happiness of mankind
schools and means of education shall
forever be encouraged
so to this day if you look in
constitutions like the current north
carolina constitution you look in iowa
kansas et cetera
it says forever in the public schools of
this state religion and morality would
be taught as well as knowledge
so they saw that as a mandate that you
can't be part of america if your schools
don't promote religion morality now
which particular denomination no we're
not doing that
but the principles of bible principles
of how we control
ourselves behave behave our morality it
all comes from there
and so they were huge into promoting
that
i mentioned that there were two
documents that just kind of turned me
around
one of them was i actually got a copy of
george washington's 1796
farewell address and that's considered
one of the most significant presidential
speeches ever given
it's interesting that we have state laws
from
1820 more than in 1820 you were required
in states
to take a written exam on four documents
every year for the first eight years of
school
and those four documents were the u.s
constitution
the declaration of independence the
state constitution
and george washington's fair will
address you had to study that you had to
know that a written exam for the first
eight years of school once a year
it's interesting that in the civil war
abraham lincoln actually issued a
general order to all the union troops
and said guys
if you're not fighting the enemy today i
want you to spend the whole day reading
george washington's farewell address
meditating on his principles thinking
about what he said same happened to
world war one with woodrow wilson
read the farewell address so we really
thought this was significant
and in the farewell address washington
is saying okay
here we are at two terms i'm leaving
retiring
you all know what we've been through and
he talks about economics he talks about
what happened with the revolution
and he says and now my fellow citizens
as i leave
here's a few thoughts and they're almost
like warnings i mean one of the things
he says is
don't let the federal government get
into deficit spending you know it's one
of his great warnings
he talks about avoiding foreign
entanglements you know try to keep
sovereignty here and don't get
tied in foreign wars and so all this
wise stuff but
what he says he says of all the habits
and dispositions that lead to political
prosperity
religion and morality are indispensable
supports
he said in vain would that man claim the
tribute of patriotism
who should labor to subvert these great
pillars so he goes out saying guys
anybody that tries to separate religion
and morality from
public life from politics they're not
patriots they're trying to destroy the
nation
now that's a big litmus test and i was
told that washington was a great deist
that he was not a faith guy and here
he's saying guys don't
if anybody tries to take faith out of
the public square
they're not a patriot i'm going oh my
gosh that's not what i was taught
and so when i read his farewell address
it really got me thinking
what else did i make get taught right
and so
separation church and state's one of
those phrases that the way we use it
today
um probably the best way to explain it
the phrase
did not originate with jefferson it
originated back in the 14th and 1500s
john greenwood a pastor in great britain
is probably the first guy
credited with saying it back in the
1500s and so they wrote about it for
hundreds of years before jefferson
picked it up so he was repeating what
historical writers had said
but even in jefferson's letter which he
wrote on january the 1st 1802 that's the
famous letter of the court's quote today
on separation church and state
that letter is 233 words long it's three
paragraphs
it's easy to put a footnote in any court
case
and since 1947 no quote no court has
quoted more than eight words
a wall of separation between church and
state that's it
every court that used it before 47
quoted the whole letter
like reynolds versus united states since
in 1878
and every time they quoted the whole
letter of jefferson they said look based
on what jefferson said
separation church and state means you
can't stop a public religious activity
and so we always kept religion in public
life using the separation phrase
until a case in 47 called everson versus
board of education
and the court said oh look what
jefferson said separation we can't have
any religion alive
no read the whole there's a reason they
don't put the whole letter in there
when you read the whole letter you it's
obvious what jefferson said
because you had a group in connecticut
saying we're afraid the government's
going to shut down our religious
activities and expression he said no
there's a wall of separation between
church and state they will not stop your
religious activities
that's not what we get today so that's
the kind of stuff that really started
turning me over and saying
i wasn't taught this i got a whole
different line even
separation church and state and so if
you go back and look at what jefferson
did
oh my gosh jefferson started church
in the u.s capitol building every week
we had church in the capitol by 1857 the
largest church
protestant church in the united states
met in the capitol every week
jefferson started that he invited
preachers to preach at that church
how is that separation well that's why
we don't look at what he actually did or
said we just use a phrase from it
next to take on some of the criticisms
of american nationalism
and to make the argument that america
isn't simply held together by common
ideas
we go to rich lowry from episode 78.
rich began his career as a research
assistant at charles krauthammer and was
selected by william f buckley to lead
national review as editor in 1997.
he's a columnist for politico he's a
frequent guest on programs like meet the
press
rich has authored books like lincoln
unbound the case for nationalism how it
made us powerful united and free
and legacy paying the price for the
clinton years a new york times
bestseller
rich is one of the most creative and
intelligent minds in conservative
circles
his defense of nationalism is
particularly fascinating especially
because it's come under
such bad odor in modern american society
if you say you're a nationalist
everybody in the media simply says
you're a nazi which is insane and crazy
nationalism has an actual meaning and
there's a lot of complexity to the idea
rich and i have discussed this at length
and we discussed it in our interview as
well
in that discussion rich addresses
criticisms of american nationalism
and explains what a truthful history of
the united states should look like
how the 1619 project is unprecedented
what separates group identity from
national identity
and what truly makes us american
so let's talk about american nationalism
so the chief critique of american
nationalism is that
we're not actually a nation that we are
we're a set of of different
competing interest groups and that we
have been bound together
by fate or by military power depending
on on how you see it
but realistically the idea of a of a
common american nation that spans both
slaves and slaveholders that spans
native americans
and the people who drove them off their
land that spans oppressors and people
who were oppressed
that that is a fantasy or mirage and
that is history written by the winners
how do you respond to that
well there's there's been american
nation for a very long time
and my contention is that it predates
the revolution in 1776. i can't tell you
exactly
when the american nation arises but is
sometime between
the early 17th century where the
settlement starts here
and the revolution where you have a
people who become used to governing
themselves
that have their own governing
institutions most importantly this
colonial assemblies
that are governing for a hundred years
that's a very long time you don't get
the revolution if you don't have a
a nation prior to it that feels that it
has its own
claims and rights that need to be
vindicated
now the shortcomings of the nation
african americans are part of the
cultural nation from the very beginning
but their rights aren't recognized by
the government and the state
and native americans are pushed aside uh
by the
american nation so these are these are
two shameful
aspects of our history and i spent a lot
of time talking in the book how we need
a truthful history
of the united states that includes our
sins but it shouldn't
necessitate lying about ourselves which
is i what what we see now
in the 16 19 project the new york times
and elsewhere which is something i
think really unprecedented in human
history usually the national
tendency is you lie about the other guy
you lie about the other country to drag
them down
we have people now who are dragging our
own country
down so when we talk about people
joining the stream of american history
being admitted to the to the
the broader stream of american history
in the case of freed slaves for example
or native americans who who decide not
to live in tribal reservations which are
a separate governed area
how do people join the american nation
because if
america is a creedal idea that makes
sense but if america is more than a
creed
how do you join with a nation that has a
separate history or a separate culture
yeah so i think one of the pillars of
the american nation is
a cultural core and african americans
were contributing
to that from the very beginning i spent
some time talking in the book about how
southern culture is really impossible to
disaggregate
in certain important respects what's the
african influence and what's the
european influence
because it's all mixed up native
americans again a different case they
were
pushed aside they were excluded
and that's part of the original sin of
this country but you become
an american fundamentally by you learn
the language
you adopt the mores you thrill to the
stories
and the heroes you honor the symbols
and you believe in the ideals that makes
you
an american and something i say in talks
about this topic is if hypothetically
tonight
take a tourist metaphor an
african-american
meets a white american on the streets on
that
stairs of the paris opera house they
instantly have more in common
than anyone around them it doesn't
matter whether ideologies are different
their politics are different where they
are from this country
they have a common language a common
mode of dress likely
common cuisine tend to like the same
kind of food and a huge stock of common
cultural
references and i just don't think you
can minimize
the importance of that to what it is
to making an american so yes the creed
is important and as part of that and the
culture
and the creed interact with one another
and support one another but it's not
just a creed entirely
so philosophically what separates uh
group identity from
national identity so you know we can say
that that for example black americans
obviously are part of the american story
but there are some black americans who
say well we're not we're left out of the
american story and our chief loyalty
lies to the black american story which
is different from the general national
american story and trying to pretend
that we are just
one part of a broader american history
is selling us short
why should loyalty be to a nation in in
some cases a nation that victimized
the group to belong as opposed to the
group to which you
uh which seems closer to you in terms of
proximity
well i mean i think they're overlapping
loyalties right we're all
loyal most of all to our family we might
have
an affiliation you know if you're an
irish and american you might
uh be particularly have a connection to
ireland and saint patrick's day and um
aspects of that language and culture but
ultimately i think we're all in this
together
and none of us are what we are if
if it weren't for this country and being
born in this country is something
none of us are responsible for it's just
an incredibly gratuitous blessing
that we're here so for me that that
argues for
loyalty to the nation now
african-americans it's much more
difficult case
because they were treated unjustly
for 150 years horrifically you know i've
been reading up on
um slavery because i've been arguing
with some of the people
who wrote for the 1619 project and the
atlantic passage is something it's
almost impossible to read about
is so nauseatingly horrifying
but the the story of african-americans
is
of loyalty to this country the the
emphasis on african-american has to be
american and the lead essay in the new
york times 1619 project i think was
actually moving and correct
on this topic participated in every
american war even when they had no
rights or returning or returning to a
country that was going to
oppress them and this very moving
anecdote in an essay
where the author describes being a
little girl in school
and the teacher has some project where
all the students are going to point to
the country on the globe
that their family is originally from and
her her and her african-american friend
they have no idea they have no idea
where to point because they're so
american exactly because they're so
american and because of
various factors including that we didn't
import many slaves here compared to
caribbean
islands and our immigration policy was
racist and we didn't welcome
african-americans
for that reason if you're an
african-american and your family didn't
immigrate fairly recently your lineage
in this country
goes way way way back and in that sense
you're more american
than any of the european american
neo-nazis in charlottesville for
instance
i get into the philosophy of
conservatism in episode 56 with the
great one
mark levin host of the mark levinshow
one of the most respected political
radio shows in the country
he also hosts life liberty and levin on
fox news hugely rated show
he was the first editor-in-chief of
conservative review and he's authored
several new york times bestsellers
including his latest on freedom of the
press
prior to his radio and tv days mark
served as an advisor to many members of
president reagan's cabinet eventually
becoming chief of staff
to attorney general ed meese mark was
awarded the american conservative
union's ronald reagan award for his work
at landmark legal foundation
an american conservative legal advocacy
group where he served as president
i'm a long time admirer of mark levin
meeting him was one of the great thrills
of my young life and becoming a
colleague is an even bigger thrill
mark is one of the most intelligent
commentators on the political scene he
knows his founding philosophy
down to his marrow he understands the
law and he understands the threat from
the left
frankly i'm honored to be considered a
colleague of my friend mark levin in our
conversation
listen to us discuss the fight to define
conservatism what we need to teach every
american
the narrative shift away from
appreciation of our founding and how the
declaration of independence as
originally written is what enabled this
country to abolish slavery
[Music]
i don't think donald trump is a
philosophical conservative
i think he's come to his conservatism as
a matter of practicality
and in some ways principle
i and so i don't think he's any more
a principled or philosophical
conservative than george w
bush george h.w bush i think they've
really been two
in the last little over a century that
would be coolidge and reagan
but other than that i can't think of any
just off the top of my head
not nixon not ford not eisenhower
certainly not theodore roosevelt and
harding and so forth so
i don't really hold that against him
in terms of him uh promoting that kind
of an agenda
from a philosophical point of view uh
but i think it's
kind of that not our job but our
responsibility to try and explain that
to a lot of people what these policies
are our philosophy
and so forth i even think a lot of
so-called conservative websites and
magazines
have lost their way they're fighting
with each other of what conservatism
means
or they've abandoned it in some ways
because they hate trump or they loved
her or whatever the situation is
i i feel right now the intellectual
conservative movement is very weak
i really do uh i think you and i and
others
try to present that case but as from a
broad-based perspective
it's quite weak and i think that's a
problem
because some people are abandoning it
i'm not sure why a hundred percent um
i'm very troubled by some who've talked
about conservatism all these years and
then all of a sudden say well
what has it ever done for us and i said
let me tell you what it's done for you
nine o'clock tonight i want you to go
into one of these supermarkets
where i live they have a place called
wegmans i don't know if they have them
in california
it's as big as a football field and i
want you to walk down
every aisle 10 different types of
toothpaste
you can get battery operated
toothbrushes or handheld
soft medium heart then i want you to go
to the meat section
and i want to see how many types of meat
the chicken section go to the wine
section
wine from all over the world just look
stop telling me conservatism doesn't
work and capitalism doesn't work we
we are the we we have more
material things in this country
and any king or queen had 200 years ago
we get on an airplane we fly across the
country and that's not socialism that's
not big government
those are airplanes it's technology
that's creativity
and we complain whether they have
peanuts or pretzels on the plane or
whether we're sitting on the tarmac for
an extra half hour right
we need to we need to put things in
perspective the things we have in this
country
almost no other country has certainly
two-thirds of the world doesn't have why
do you think
millions of people are trying to claw
their way into this country because
why because because the middle class
is is under attack because we have
systemic racism
because we're not socialist enough no
it's because of all the other reasons
and so um
part of it is the responsibility of the
individual citizen
honestly i don't look to the president
of the united states or a senator or a
politician of it kind of tell me
this is what you need to think one of
the things that we need to continue to
teach people is think for yourselves
that's a good thing learn for you most
of the stuff i've learned about the
constitution i sure as hell didn't learn
in public school
i've learned it since i've been in
school and that's a good thing
the learning process goes on and on and
on but
not again the first chapter of liberty
and tyrion i say one of the reasons why
we don't really appreciate liberty
is because we're surrounded by it and
one of the reasons we don't appreciate
what we have is because we're surrounded
by it and so we get caught up in really
stupid arguments
our focus is so off um
and then we had d-day the anniversary
75th henry the other day
and i played these old clips from world
war ii and you really
your patriotism is just through the roof
and you see
how tremendous this country is and the
sacrifices
people have made for this country so i
think it's really on each one of us more
than eight
president to really explain liberty and
conservatism and constitutionalism
and this president doesn't do that
anyway most presidents
don't do that like i said i can think of
two who basically did
but i will say this strongly in support
of the president
he doesn't preach the other too how
rotten america
is you know how racist america is
uh the wage gaps in america i mean i can
you know
people can't get health care in america
so he's not one of them
and so and at his core i know he loves
this country
this is one of the things that's been
troubling me so much about the
democratic party
i make a distinction in my language
routinely between leftist and liberal
liberals are people i disagree with on
politics leftists are people who want to
shut down the debate who are interested
in polarizing people specifically on the
basis of race
for political gain and and it seems like
the left has taken over completely the
democratic party
is interesting i was watching with my
wife an old movie the other night movie
called born yesterday with judy holliday
and
and uh broderick crawford and the movie
is from 1950 it's an
incredibly patriotic film and the entire
film is basically william holden showing
judy holiday around the city of
washington dc and she he brings her to
see the constitution
and the declaration of independence they
go to the jefferson memorial and he's
telling her all about the wonderful
founding philosophy
and i turned to my wife and i said
there's no way this movie gets made
today because the entire narrative of
the left has shifted
even in my lifetime i'm old enough to
remember when the democratic party
actually still
at least paid lip service to the
foundations of the country and talked
about
how wonderful founding philosophy was
and now it seems that the narrative is
dominant in the democratic party
that the founding philosophy was
effectively just racism sexism bigotry
and homophobia
dressed up in fancy clothes and then
sold to people and that what we really
have to do is cleanse the palate get rid
of all these documents and start afresh
obviously it scares the hell out of me
i'm seeing young people who don't know
anything about history buying into it
how do you combat all of that you know
the institution that is that they really
needs to be
dealt with in one form or another is
education
uh public education and universities and
colleges and you and i fund them the
american people are funding our own
demise
somehow people get tenure not all but
too many
vast majority in our public schools the
nea the aft
and our colleges and universities they
get tenure
and they are people who reject our
founding principles
i mean i i i always wonder
how many battles of the civil war
actually taught in high school
each battle is so incredible so unique
how many battles in world war
ii how many battles of the revolutionary
war do kids do they know what lexington
and concord is all about
um these are things that would inspire
patriotism
and support for the country instead
you're right
the founders had uh no uh positive uh
uh characteristics they were slaves so
they must be dismissed
and yet it was abraham lincoln who did
the greatest job of explaining
the founding and the founders and did
more
for african-american slaves in this
country than any left-wing professor
or any leftist on tv that you can
imagine
he led the civil war and what lincoln
said in 1858 and beyond
and he loved the founders he said those
men wrote the declaration of
independence
there's not a word about slavery in the
declaration of independence
every individual is created by god
unalienable rights
he said so the men those men knew that
slavery was wrong
but they also could not create a country
because certain states like georgia and
south carolina weren't going to go for
it
but they knew that their children and
their grandchildren would have to
address this that's why they wrote the
declaration of independence the way that
they did
and he says it's their writing
their constitution that will enable us
to smite this because otherwise we
wouldn't have had a country
and you still would have had states or
colonies with slavery
and states and colonies without it
but history is not taught it certainly
wasn't even when i was in
high school i still got the same pablum
the same left-wing agenda
they have managed the progressive
movement to really
control ideologically virtually every
instrumentality of our culture right now
that's why we have these culture wars
whether it's the courts
whether it's whether it's the
bureaucracy whether it's education
whether it's the media we always start
with the progressive foundation and
we're always on defense
uh trying to respond to these things
we've got to do something about
colleges and universities and i think we
the people need to start
speaking with our wallets and states
need to start with holding funds you're
going to be subsidized well don't be
subsidized so much
make sure when you send your kid to
college if you're involved in that
decision
that you don't send them to an
indoctrination mill you know just
because it's an ivy league school
doesn't mean they have to go there
there's other schools out there where
they'll get a more traditional education
and so on
but this is something i've been thinking
a lot about maybe one day i'll write
about it and give it more focused
thought
but it is a huge huge problem
to end with an uplifting guest from the
show discussing some of the aspects and
values that all
americans can and should get behind
let's go to episode 41
arthur brooks arthur is the former
president of the american enterprise
institute conservative think tank
committed to defending human dignity
and building a freer world he is now
faculty for harvard business school and
harvard kennedy school
he's written the new york times
bestsellers the road to freedom how to
win the fight for free enterprise
the conservative heart how to build a
fairer happier and more prosperous
america
and several others arthur brooks is
legitimately the nicest person
in the entire world when he writes books
about how we should be nicer to each
other you think
who is this guy and what sort of
saccharin nonsense is this
and then you read the books and they are
filled with content and depth
and it turns out that arthur is just a
deep abiding
loving person just a wonderful guy also
he happens to be a classical
french hornets you don't find that very
often i'm a classical violinist so at
some point we'll have to play duets
listen to us discuss finding commonality
between all americans
and recognizing the blessings of
capitalism and our free enterprise
system
in your book you talk about we've talked
a little bit here about the gradations
in terms of you know who's worthy of
contempt so the taliban worthy of
contempt
but you know in the united states the
idea is that we are while we think that
we may be enemies we're actually not
enemies we're brothers in
the link in sort of lincolnian
formulation i want to ask if that's
really true
and the reason i want to ask that is
because as certain people on both sides
become more radical i think right now
the left is moving in a radical
direction faster than the right is
donald trump is actually in policy
somewhat of a moderate republican
the left seems to be moving pretty
dramatically in a far left direction
including
embrace of democratic socialism you talk
about these sort of moral values that
you still think
unite americans what do you think those
moral values are
and are you are you overstating the case
do you think that we have more in common
than we may actually have in common
i may be overstating the case but i want
to err on that side
why because one of the things that i've
noticed is that leaders throughout
history who are truly aspirational
they're not populist because you know
populism is fundamentally not leadership
it's followership
it's basically and you've made this
point a hundred times like i stole this
from ben shapiro but there's a there's a
parade going down the street
a populist is a guy who says there's a
parade i better get out in front of it
they need a leader
leadership is something that says
there's a better future can you see it
there's a guy who teaches at
harvard business school named named
daniel goldman and he talks about
authoritative leadership which is not
you must come with me it's not coercive
it says do you see a better future
do you want it maybe people don't want
it but in point of fact you have to look
at the horizon you have to look at the
moral horizon you have to say this is
something better
and to hold americans to their highest
and best values
that's a good thing to do are we there
no am i there
not every day but i want to be there and
i want america to be there and so i'm
looking for what i think is the kind of
the moral
dna of this country and the morality in
this country unambiguously
believes in the radical equality of
human dignity why because
you make this point in your new book
everybody's got to get this book
because it talks about how how these how
these judeo-christian
values these western values are a gift
to the world
people even if they're not religious and
we have a lot of people watching us who
are atheists who are secular completely
but they believe in the quality of human
dignity why because we have a culture
that's based on the idea that
each one of us is made in god's image
god is worthy of respect
that's the essence of dignity and so
each one of us is worthy of dignity
that's what americans actually believe
furthermore the reason that the
you know the people came here in the
first place is because we believe in the
limitlessness of human potential
so let's call americans to dignity and
potential are they living up to it no
will they ever live up to it completely
not my lifetime but i'm going to work in
a social movement
in an intellectual movement and in a
media movement i'm going to work with
you
we're going to work together to try to
help americans live up to those
standards even though we haven't hit
them yet i mean i certainly agree with
all of that i wonder if there are active
opponents to some of that and
the reason i say that is because you put
you point out jonathan heights moral
matrix jonathan's been on the program
professor height and he and we talked
about the the five factors
maybe six if you include liberty which
she added later um and you talk about
how conservatives and
and liberals still believe in a couple
of them the same
or compassionate compassion and fairness
but even those ones
as as professor height has recognized
are seen in almost diametrically opposed
ways so fairness for
conservatives is fairness in the
meritocratic sense the idea that we all
have equal rights but that the outcome
is not going to be equal
and fairness for many on the democratic
side is fairness of outcome which is
directly opposed to fairness
of meritocracy right when it comes to
compassion on the right side of the
aisle
the value system tends to be well
compassion is me helping you find a job
develop a skill set care for yourself
and compassion on the left side of the
aisle is how do i
create a system whereby you don't have
to care for yourself whereby we are
caring for you that's that's real
compassion
so if that's the case then even the most
basic values the ones that are necessary
for us to be playing the same game so to
speak
have those been radically undermined or
do you think that there are bridges that
can still be built i think there are
bridges and the reason is because let's
take something like fairness where the
right
really does focus on meritocratic
fairness it's
don't take something that somebody else
earned and the left really does
focus much more on redistributive
fairness the idea of redistributing
somebody has more somebody has less the
person who has left
less needs more you take it from the
person who has more okay i got it
but that doesn't mean that you and i who
are guys on the center right or on the
right
don't believe in any redistribution
that's wrong you believe that there
should be a welfare state and so do i i
mean i i believe that the the free
enterprise system one of the greatest
accomplishments
ever the free enterprise system was our
ability to support people we've never
even met
it's incredible thing that no system in
history has been able to accomplish is
because of capitalism
because of the largest that came from
capitalism and it's such a blessing i'm
so proud of it
and that means i believe in some amount
of redistribution i'm just more
meritocratic in that balance
you know i know a ton of people on the
left i have tons of friends and family i
mean i used to be a musician
and a college professor and i come from
seattle washington for pete's sake i
know a lot of people on the left
and and they don't they don't think that
merits garbage they think that merits
great because they want their kids to
achieve and
they're kind of proud to live in a
country where people can start companies
and do great things they just
they want a little bit more
redistribution now you find radicals and
and when i say this i mean that
the set approximately depending on your
account at the seven percent of people
who are
true polarizing radicals in this country
who don't see any common ground
but if 93 percent of us give or take
actually
do believe that there can be some common
ground that we can work together in some
way shape or form then i'm going to be
bridging that meritocratic
redistributive divide
and i'm going to be really forgiving i'm
going to be as generous as i possibly
can to the people who don't agree
quite as much with my meritocratic
values so i can try to get some fairness
that bridges that gap and i think it can
be done
this is why i love your new book so much
because it really spoke to me it
reminded me this epiphany i had in my
late 20s when i was studying for my
bachelor's degree
i took economics for the first time and
i and i learned this crazy thing
that 80 percent of the world's poverty
had been eradicated since i was a kid
you know i thought that hunger was worse
i thought that the world was worse
and furthermore i thought capitalism was
great for rich people and bad for poor
people
and you know and i grew up in a
left-wing environment and i
knew nobody who cared about economics or
business but i was learning
that 2 billion of my brothers and
sisters had been pulled out of poverty
since i was a child
and i learned that it came from five
things
five things and all economists left
right and center this is not
controversial stuff this is not
this is propaganda five things pulled
two billion of ben and arthur's brothers
and sisters out of poverty since 1970 it
was globalization
free trade property rights the rule of
law
and the culture of free enterprise
spreading from america
all around the world i thought huh you
know you know
my favorite composer in those days was
johan sebastian bach you know the
greatest composer ever lived and he was
asked
near the end of his life why do you
write music his answer was
the aim and final end of all music is
nothing less than the glorification of
god
and the refreshment of the soul i
thought to myself
how can i answer like bach i wasn't
answering like back as a french horn
player in the orchestra i thought i want
to do
something that glorifies god and it
refreshes the lives of other people
and i became an economist
from the sublime to the dismal
if you've enjoyed hearing from our past
guests in this collection be sure to
check out their full episodes and hear
more of the conversation
links to those are in the description
also be sure to leave us a comment about
who some of your favorite past sunday
special guests have been
and who you'd like to see me talk with
next season we'll see you next time
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover executive
producer jeremy boring
associate producer katie swinnerton our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
post production is supervised by alex
singaro editing is by jim nicholl
audio is mixed by michael coromina hair
and makeup is by nico geneva
title graphics are by cynthia angulo the
ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2020.
you